foreign
[Music]
platforms is laying off 13 of its
Workforce or more than 11
000 employees it is one of the biggest
Tech layoffs this year as the Facebook
parent battle soaring costs and a weak
advertising Market
[Music]
almost every major tech company in the
world likes to claim that they operate
like a startup despite being worth
hundreds of billions or even trillions
these companies like to claim that
nothing has changed in terms of their
company culture relative to when they
begin this means that they're still
hyper focused on growth everyone has to
wear multiple hats and most importantly
they run a lean ship of course Silicon
Valley startups rarely do any of this
but traditionally this is how a startup
would operate Amazon is arguably the
most infamous company making these
claims and in one regard it's true
whether you're a tech worker or a
factory worker Amazon is gonna work you
to the Bone just like a startup but
unlike a startup almost all of these
companies also engage in over hiring and
we're not talking about over hiring a
little here or a little there no we're
talking about systemic overhiring of
tens of thousands of people and it's
super obvious too take Facebook for
example at the end of 2019 it they had a
total of 45 000 employees but by
September of 2022 they added 87 000
employees this means that Facebook's
employee account nearly doubled within
these three years Facebook obviously
does not need twice as many employees to
run the same services that were already
massive at three years ago or create
platforms that 38 people use this
usually isn't a big deal during bull
markets when the market is doing well
and investors are happy but during
recessions companies almost instantly
turn around and lay off everyone that
they over hired going back to Facebook
they laid off 11 000 people even
companies that are doing relatively well
end up in the situation take Google for
example Google's net income has barely
dipped and is still hovering near
all-time highs yet Google is receiving
significant pressure to reduce their
work for Course and there are rumors
that Google is looking to lay off 10 000
people but why even play this game why
hire to fire wouldn't it make more sense
to run a lean ship at all times like a
startup this way during Good Times their
profit margins will be even higher and
during bad times they won't have to shed
too much of their Workforce if any I
mean it seems pretty straightforward yet
most of these companies till over higher
so here's what companies over hire just
to end up laying off
foreign
practices can be linked back to one
simple human emotion fear the fear of
missing out during periods of hyper
growth it seems like everyone around you
is investing and growing way faster than
you this was very much true for Amazon
from the pandemic bottom Amazon stock
grew about 132 percent which is a great
number but from Amazon's perspective
many of their peers grew substantially
more Facebook grew 180 percent Google
grew 200 Apple grew 240 and heck even
the S P 500 grew 120 percent looking at
it like this amazona barely beat the
market and they significantly
underperformed their peers now the smart
thing to do would be to identify areas
in which Amazon could have fundamentally
grow but oftentimes what happens is that
they look at what their peers are doing
and more times than not their peers are
pouring craploads of money into research
and development for example Facebook was
was pouring a hundred billion dollars
into the metaverse and when Amazon sees
this they think ah that must be the key
if we want to grow at the pace of
Facebook we have to double down on R D
and that this is exactly how you end up
with the projects like Alexa that are
mass money pits during bull markets it's
easy to say that these Investments are
for the Long Haul but when things turn
around it doesn't take long for
companies to get a reality check aside
from over investing it into r d
companies also end up over investing
into marketing when companies realize
that they're falling behind competitors
a natural response is to become more
aggressive with marketing this includes
hiring a bunch of sales people pumping
up ad budgets and creating an overly
generous referral programs this over
investment is only made worse by the
positive feedback loops that follow as
companies pump up marketing it'll
actually appear like the investment is
worth it they'll have a great
click-through rate conversion rates and
custom acquisition costs so they'll end
up spending even more on marketing
they'll also hire a bunch of new
developers Solutions Architects and
managers to keep up with this demand but
in reality much of this code can be
explained by consumer sentiment as
you're probably aware the bull market
phone mode doesn't just affect companies
it also affects the general public when
you see your friends and family buy new
cars and houses you naturally feel a
sense of security and safety as it feels
like everything is going well this
doesn't necessarily mean that you go out
and buy a car yourself but maybe you
might be a bit more loose when it comes
to your Amazon spending or you might
keep your subscriptions that you don't
actually use but when a recession rolls
around and you see your friends and
family losing their jobs and struggling
to make payments you're naturally going
to put off that iPhone upgrade and eat
out less when companies see this it'll
appear as if their sales team is no
longer as effective so they'll end up
scaling back on their sales team which
in turn means scaling back the rest of
the company
and may not seem like it but over hiring
is actually oftentimes a defensive move
here's the thing when things are going
well employees are usually pretty
confident they'll be willing to ask for
promotions look for other jobs and join
riskier organizations and a given that
everyone is chucking a bunch of money
into sales and r d it's usually not that
difficult for these employees to find a
better job all of a sudden it getting
into the most prestigious companies
won't be as impossible as it once seemed
and joining a crypto brokerage it won't
seem as irresponsible as it once seemed
also we're not talking about the nominal
increases to your salary like going from
60 000 to 70 000 we're talking about
jumps like seventy thousand to a hundred
and twenty thousand or 150 000 to 280
000 I mean you just have to take one
look at this company's salary is to
understand it just how much they're
willing to pay to track the best talent
at the same time even employees that
don't leave will be more confident in
setting boundaries while these guys
ended up sticking around they're usually
well aware that they could switch just
like their peers they probably also see
a bunch of vacancies around them which
means that the company is struggling to
hire enough Talent all of this shows
that the employer is more dependent on
the employee than the employee is
dependent on the employer this means
that the employee is unlikely to work
outside of their regular hours or take
on work that's outside their scope this
is pretty much exactly what we were
seeing until recently everyone was
resigning and switching jobs or they
were quiet quitting companies are
acutely aware of this but they really
can't do much about it if they force
their employees to be more productive
more of them will probably leave which
will just mean that the company has even
more positions to fill out likely at
higher salaries as well to combat this
companies have to over hire to account
for the lower productivity and higher
churn this was the case just one year
ago at the end of 2021 Mark Zuckerberg
was irritated that Facebook wasn't able
to meet their recruiting targets as
especially with experienced engineers in
fact Facebook was struggling to get even
half of their applicants to accept job
offers despite literally offering
Millions but this entire Dynamic turns
on its head during a recessionary period
for one employees are not only less
likely to leave but they're also more
likely to be productive because they
want to keep their jobs this suddenly
means that you can accomplish all the
same tasks with just 70 or 80 of your
Workforce at the same time a new hires
start piling up as well before you have
to recruit like crazy just to maintain
your head count and account for the
massive churn but now all of these new
hires quickly become a dead weight for
the company for example let's say the
company was over hiring by 10 if their
existing staff suddenly it becomes 30
more productive the company is no longer
overstaffed by just 10 percent they're
overstaffed by 40 and at this point
there's nothing left to do but bring out
the chopper
thank you
the point that we've discussed so far
are reasonably understandable during
bull markets companies are often fearful
of falling behind it and they're forced
to over hire just to keep up when market
dynamics shift however this often
results in massive layoffs while this no
doubt sucks and it's at least somewhat
understandable what's not understandable
however is the third subset of reasons
that companies over hire which is the
nefarious upset one of the most
nefarious of these is the practice of
hiring it to fire at first glance this
Probably sounds super counter-intuitive
and it is why would anyone spend so much
time money and effort into vetting and
interviewing thousands of applicants
just to turn around and to fire them
well let's just say that it's not
something that anyone really wants to do
but certain corporate policies make this
a reality for example Amazon requires
that the bottom 10 of their Workforce be
let go on an annual basis if you're an
Amazon manager this would be easy if you
have a crappy worker on your team but
unfortunately most Amazon managers
aren't that lucky given that everyone
that they hire for the corporate side
are exceptional if they were to score
their team members the worst performer
might be given a 90
obviously there is some room for
improvement but it's definitely not a
fireable offense managers very much
understand that this would be unfair and
that's why they turned to hiring to fire
they usually maintain a core team of
seven to ten people that they want to
keep permanently and every year they'll
hire some random sucker who will be
tasked with doing all of the dirty work
for the team for a year before getting
fired if a given sucker truly does an
exceptional job there is a chance that
they'll be allowed to stick around but
this means that someone else on the team
now has to be fired insteaded and this
is by design a lot of companies don't
care about tenure or experience in fact
they feel like these attributes make an
employee less productive because they've
become too comfortable these companies
would much rather have a bunch of
short-term employees that work their
butts off the entire time they're there
and this forces managers to either hire
to fire or hire to replace it's truly
quite a vicious practice but it's not
just Amazon who's guilty of this most
old-school corporate Giants practice
some form of this think companies like
GE IBM and even Microsoft up until 2013.
we shouldn't note however that it wasn't
until after 2013 that Microsoft finally
started to grow again so this practice
is definitely just as counterproductive
as it sounds but nonetheless many
companies still practice it leading to
constant over hiring followed by layoffs
and firing
foreign
while it might be easy to say that
companies should just hire what they
need it's usually not that simple the
underlying problem is that the number of
employees that a company needs is simply
not constant Facebook having a hundred
thousand employees in 2021 it might not
have been enough but Facebook having a
hundred thousand employees in 2022 is
definitely Overkill when everyone is
spending and buying it companies that
naturally need more employees conversely
when everyone is pulling back companies
needed less employees combine this with
varying levels of productivity and
opportunities and that this issue just
becomes even more magnified but this
doesn't mean that companies that are
completely innocent either many of them
engage in terrible practices like hiring
to fire or hiring to replace which not
only increases churn but also creates a
horrendous workplace culture which makes
the entire organization less productive
really the only way to avoid this is to
join some sort of background company
like an energy company or a water
company or of course the government but
for the rest of us well we'll probably
have to deal with these corporate games
throughout the rest of our careers but
that's just what I think what are your
thoughts on hiring to fire comment that
down below also drop a like if you're
hoping that the layoffs end sooner
rather than later and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as fertility ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on next one